foreign
Boston hi Amy how are you
hi there I'm doing well thank you so
much for taking my call I'm pretty
nervous here no troubles what's up
um yeah so my husband and I are on baby
step two
um we are both 52 years old
um so we got a little bit of a late
start
um we have paid off like a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars since the
beginning of 2020. very good
um yeah but like at 76 or so thousand of
that has just been since um in the last
18 months or so
um so we are plugging along plugging
along
um and my question is and I I've heard
you guys answer this a similar version
of this question but what do you do when
you're not fully fully on the same page
with your spouse with regard to How
Deeply you're willing to sacrifice like
we're mostly on the same page and like I
said you know we're making great
progress but we have like 32 000 left
um and
my husband and I had a little situation
with the heat at our house because oil
is like over five dollars a gallon
so I was keeping the heat turned off
um and he was away on a work trip and he
turned the heat on and he was like
I'm sorry I am not you know I'm not
willing to wear a coat and a hat in my
house
um and
so I just I'm so stressed about heating
season
amen and how like we can afford it Amy
yes what's your household income
our household income is about 154 000.
your husband's right
okay Amy this is not about I'm not I'm
not wearing listen I teach intensity
and the the depth of your sacrifice
will be based on the depth of your
intensity
and the depth of all of that is going to
be based on the depth of your why and uh
you're you're talking to Mr get
everybody out of debt Dave Ramsey and I
am not going to wear a coat in my house
I felt like he was being a drama queen
he's cold you are
Amy there's something below this what is
it there's something beneath this this
is not about heat what is it
have you been carrying a lot of this are
you scared
well are you tired
I'm definitely tired I'm definitely
tired
um
and like I am clearly the nerd in the
relationship if you guys couldn't tell
yeah um yep loud and clear and I'm high
intensity he is the Yes man he is you
know the free spirit for sure
and but he's been going along with you
pretty good because you paid off 76 000
in the last 18 months yeah he had he had
and you just you crossed the line when
you when you made the man cold
hey Amy listen listen
okay Andy listen you ever been driving
down the highway and you got to go to
the bathroom and you you don't know when
the next exit is and so your body just
kind of settles into like a constant
like I gotta go but I'm fine and then
you exit and you get right to the gas
station and all of a sudden your body's
like it's happening right now and you
have to Sprint that last 15 feet into
the into the gas station for the last 15
miles you've been okay that's right
right that's where you are you are
several years into this you see the
finish on your 30 grand away you're
almost there
don't lose your marriage over a couple
hundred bucks I'm so pissed at Biden for
the oil prices yeah yeah don't yeah turn
the news off
like yes it's it's heat it's it's heat
it is what it is and it's just I praise
the lord we can afford it that's right
here's the other thing I'll tell you
this what this means is there's a shirt
there's every marriage book I've ever
read says that you have a healthy
marriage if you argue about the
thermostat
every every couple I've ever met in my
life argues about the thermostat me and
my wife are going to be married I've
been married 40 years and I still can't
convince Sharon how a thermostat works
and its purpose is just to hold the
temperature she thinks if she cranks it
up or down it makes it go faster
I'm like this isn't we got through the
worst of it the temperature
week I'm like
stop whining and then my husband comes
home from a chip and he's like I am not
wearing a coat and hat in my house he's
right he's right you know and the good
news is you're you're
uh uh you know he's willing to say that
and not just go crazy on you and you're
willing to laugh about it when we poke a
little fun at you because we've all done
stuff just exactly like you're doing and
like he's doing for that matter but you
really have done a great job so far and
you really are going to get there you're
almost and you really don't have to skip
a meal to do it
oh my gosh I feel I'm so grateful for
the encouragement and you really don't
have to live in a cold house how many
more months away you I know you've got
it you've already got that number
tattooed on your wrist how soon
probably
seven to eight months yeah or less
alcohol is like when our when our fourth
kid graduates from high school it's like
I wanted by then within five months I
think you're gonna do it in five months
you can do it you're there's other
things are gonna happen but the what the
weird thing is the math works better
when you're working together versus when
you've sacrificed so much that you lost
your partner and you lost the
connectivity and the unity of the
relationship that somehow causes the
math to get better more so than
alienating them over the temperature in
the in the house or whatever the thing
is you know so uh now you know if it was
if it was something else if it was like
I demand to go out to eat I would tell
him to quit being a drama queen I demand
to go on vacation I deserve a vacation I
say shut up you whining snowflake I
would I would have got after him right
but but you know but all the men wanted
was Heat
what was the temperature
it was 52. good job
hey and you haven't told us the truth
you took the toilet paper out of the
house too already didn't you
oh cold there over the week
they're called too yeah she's got a
senior in high school it's going to be
telling his counselor when he's 42 that
his mother actually froze him to death
while his dad was out of town on behalf
of mental health practitioners of
America we want to thank you for keeping
us in business for the next 30 Years
man that's so precious what's precious
is is not the situation but how she's
handling it yes and how he's handling it
like I say their marriage clearly
um he's he was able to get up into the
line he's walked alongside with her for
three years he's he's put the work in
Andy's also able to speak his needs out
loud which a lot of men won't do
they just live in resentment and anger
and they go to the bar and complain
about their wife hey good for you man
good for you all got a healthy marriage
it's good yeah
thermostat Wars are a way of life
and just it's just part of it you turn
it up turn it down I got up yesterday
morning she's got it cranked down just
because she likes cold house not because
she's trying to save money yeah she just
wants to freeze me out
my wife would love to take up residence
on the Sun
wants to live on the sun and I don't
understand it